foreign
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Wednesday May 24th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Elon Musk often has a lot to say Andy
says a lot of it on Twitter just one of
the companies he owns at the Wall Street
journals CEO Council Summit yesterday he
addressed some of the most pressing
questions about the platform and the
role he hopes it will play in the next
election here are highlights from his
conversation with Thorold Barker the
wsj's editor for Europe the Middle East
and Africa I'm actually going to start
somewhere a little bit differently than
I expected
um because I just saw on Twitter on
Twitter
um a little announcement I see your
interviewing Rhonda Sanchez is that
right on Twitter spaces yes I
um
will be interviewing
Ron Sanchez and he has quite an
announcement to make and you've been
tweeting some Tim Scott stuff in the
last few days what should we be thinking
about uh who you're back yes I mean I'm
not at this time
um planning to endorse any particular
candidate but I am interested in uh
you know X slash Twitter being somewhat
of a public town square and uh where
more and more organizations host content
and make announcements on Twitter
um it's the it's the only place in the
internet to really get uh real-time like
down to the minute and second news I
look forward to the uh to the
conversation what I wanted to start with
you've just flown in I think in the last
20 minutes
um you live a pretty hectic lifestyle
what is a day in the life of Elon Musk
what does that look like well my days
are very long and complicated as you
might imagine yeah
um and um and there's a great there's a
great deal of context switching so
um
doesn't mean my life called like
relating to Doom where it's like fear is
not the mind killer context switching is
uh so switching context is is quite
painful but
um
I do generally try to divide
uh companies that's predominantly one
company on one day so today is a Tesla
day for example
um although I might end up at Twitter
late tonight
um and then tomorrow would be partly a
Tesla day as well so the time management
is extremely difficult you're running
three very big companies you have very
big stakes and you know ownership
control of of two of those at least
um
what is your succession plan if you
suddenly call and execute what you're
doing succession is one of the toughest
age-old problems there is no obvious
solution I mean there are particular
individuals identified as that I've told
look if something happens to me
unexpectedly this is who my this is my
recommendation for taking over but it
sounds like it's something that you I
mean you need to get planning of who
those people are going to be because as
you've said whether when you look at
SpaceX you look at Tesla you look at
Twitter these these matter to society a
lot and having the right people
to take those votes on the future of
where they go and where money gets spent
is is fairly important
yes absolutely now the goals the
companies their the achievement of those
goals varies considerably in difficulty
um you know the the original goal of
Tesla was to accelerate the Advent of
sustainable energy which actually I
think we've done done that to a
significant degree
um and have actually it's kind of of uh
it's kind of it's kind of Auto industry
CEO is to often acknowledge Tesla's role
in accelerating
electric vehicles
um
and um
yeah so so that that I feel has a lot of
momentum
they're still solving self-driving which
were you know aspirationally hoping to
do this year uh
and um
and so Tesla got a long way to go but
but the execution plan is relatively
clear
um
and uh
dedex that execution plan will
generate a lot of positive cash flow for
the company so it's like if it's a
fairly obvious thing to do with SpaceX
it's a harder problem because the
long-term objective is to make life
multi-planetary with a self-sustaining
City on Mars which is likely to be very
casual or negative uh at first and very
much a long term because let's just say
the target market on Mars is small
um you just hired a new CEO uh Linda
Linda yaccarino
um an ad veteran um into Twitter you
usually focus on hiring Engineers you
know Linda is a very different person
can you just quickly tell us
about your courtship how did that go
down
we had conversations over a number of
months uh just relating to advertising
um and then uh Linda felt that um
it would be very helpful for the
advertisers to see me in person so
invited me down to a conference in Miami
which was very helpful and met with a
number of advertisers personally to
assure their you know assure them that
that Twitter is a good place to
advertise if you said to Linda that you
you are going to keep speaking your mind
whatever the commercial impact of that
and has she agreed to that is she happy
with that you aligned uh yeah and in her
role as CEO
does she have any say over moderation or
is that under you or you you do that
together
well the general principle is that
um
um we will we will hear close to the low
so for any given country
um we will try to adhere as closely to
the lowest possible there is an
important thing which is like that that
obviously doesn't mean that say
advertisers uh should be forced to
appear next to any content so we've also
developed adjacency controls that ensure
that if what you're advertising is um
like Disney Disney for example is a big
Advertiser if it doesn't use advertising
a children's movie they you know want
the the contents nearby to be sort of
family friendly that's totally
understandable are you back near
profitability now Twitter is not quite
there but if we get lucky we might be
casual cash flow positive next month
um but it remains to be seen you've
created a new AI company
yourself obviously there's a huge amount
of energy and activity in this space or
at least it's been talked about I mean
what do you want to do yourself in this
space beyond Tesla and what is that new
thing well I think there should be a
significant third horse in the race here
uh we've got open air and Microsoft
Google deepmind and probably there
should be a third horse in the race so
a little bit more on that soon I agree I
don't want to jump again here on
announcements but open AI has a
relationship with Microsoft that seems
to work very well fairly well so it's
possible that
um
xai and Twitter and Tesla would have
something similar you've talked about
the importance of Regulation and you
call for this this moratorium you know
when you've been talking for years about
the need for regulation what is the
scenario that really keeps you up at
night
well I don't I don't think the AI is
going to try to destroy all Humanity but
it might
put us under strict controls isn't the
more likely nasty outcome that rather
than AI taking over and being the
ultimate Nanny that keeps us all
doing stuff that is super safe and it
wants us to that actually somebody
nefariously harnesses that power to
achieve societal control stroke military
superiority
um and that actually some country around
the world decides to use it in a
different way uh yes that's what I mean
by like AI uses as a weapon and the pen
is mightier than sword so one of the
first places we have to be careful of AI
being used is in social media to
manipulate public opinion so if we take
it back to where we started
if you look at the election that's
coming up
how big a role will this big shift in AI
capability over the last few months
which will obviously continue through
the next year how big an impact is this
going to play do you think in the
messaging and the way that people get
told
um the different pictures of of the
candidates I think that's something we
need to go look at for in a big way is
to make sure that there's we're
minimizing the impact of AI manipulation
um
it was very certainly pretty much taking
it Taking that seriously at XX Twitter
you know Twitter and um
and I think we're putting in place all
of the protections to
minimize and certainly detect when we
see large-scale manipulation of the
system Elon Musk thank you very much for
joining us
[Applause]
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]